good afternoon thank you all for coming
i'm lieutenant david valenta
with the lvmpd special victims section
i want to talk to you all today about
child
drowning and drowning prevention as
related to child death
we've already had two incidents this
year and
one death is too many especially on a
topic such as drowning which we believe
is preventable
so i want to talk about that and a few
things we can do to help everybody
prevent these because it is it's a
tragic incident that affects everybody's
life
and we could do everything we can to try
and eliminate that
through that uh first and foremost
there's no substitution
for adult supervision there's been
instances where
people don't even realize their children
have gone outside
or think their children are outside
playing unaware of the pool
or you're visiting with friends that
adult supervision is the
most paramount because these are these
are tragic scarring events when there's
a child
death we also have instances where
children suffer
life-altering injuries from
near-drowning incidents
so it's things to remember because it
can take just mere moments
it could be that moment where you go to
get a snack out of the fridge use the
restroom
check your phone text messages emails
that moment 15 seconds becomes two
minutes
that is an attorney due to a kid that
has fallen into a pool
and it's more than just pools these are
bathtubs jacuzzis
swimming pools uh and this happens this
isn't just about the
warm hot season the swimming pool season
as stated we've already had two
instances
this year that had nothing to do with
kids actually out
swimming yet they fell into swimming
pools so just want to make sure
everybody's a work
always aware always alert it could be
any body of water
as stated inside bathtubs outside the
pools
it doesn't have to be hot outside i can
tell you from experienced
children when they're out playing with
toys they drop a toy
they're gonna go after it unfortunately
they're going to go into that water for
that toy and if there is not that
immediate supervision
we unfortunately often have tragic
circumstances
so with that i'd like to remind
everybody of a few things you can do for
prevention
the abcs and d's of pool safety and
drowning prevention
the golden rule being the a the adult
supervision
that is at the forefront because nothing
else can substitute that the actual eyes
on being aware where are your children
putting eyes on them when they're
swimming when they're bathing
always be checking make sure you're not
being distracted
the bee is going to be for the barriers
it's often important when you have a
pool
if you have children be aware of a
pool safety fence make sure it has a
locking mechanism
to keep kids from accessing the pool
because even outside of the hot summer
months
the kids are going to want to go outside
and play they should be able to do that
without having to worry about the pool
so having that pool safety barrier
having pool safety covers are important
to keep kids
out of the water regardless of the time
and temperature of the year
the c is going to be for classes it's
important to teach your kids
how to swim that will always be
beneficial giving them the
the proper skills to prepare themselves
if they are to fall in any body of water
as well parents should all take cpr
classes in that horrible event
they can do what they can to save their
children's lives
and then finally the d is going to be
your devices that's going to be
everything from your flotation devices
your
life safety vest anything you can
floatation devices
tools you can throw into a pool to save
a kid there's also devices such as
alarming your doors as stated we've had
instances
where people did not even know their
children are outside by the pool
that's where your door alarms any alarm
any door that can access a backyard
would be beneficial to have safety
latches have alerts
that will let you know that your kit is
gone outside near a body of water
there's additional tools such as safety
bracelets
wave monitors bluetooth alerts you can
put on
a kid's bracelet gets wet it'll
immediately alert you
so there's tons of options and devices
that can help keep your family and
children safe
but ultimately none of those substitute
that uh
firsthand adult supervision so with that
we just hope that everybody uh
understands and listens to the
precautions we we give out here today
because we'd much rather
you see and hear us today than to have
us actually show up
as first responders at your house on a
tragic accident
with that i will take any questions
they were both just tragic accidents we
still
work with the state we investigate
everything fully
we've found that both were just tragic
accidents this year so far
been approximately three years old this
year and over the last few years they
seem to hover around
your one and a half to three four years
of age
absolutely great question and our public
information office is going to push out
a video
that will really illustrate that point
that shows how quickly you can
be distracted and a child can go face
down
and it's just a matter of moments so
we've had
several instances where it is it's it is
that fast
someone goes the check email check email
and just loses track for just mere
moments and we have
had tragic accidents to also just near
drowning accidents
absolutely depending on the age and size
of the child
all bodies of water can be considered a
risk and a hazard everything from
bathing children in kitchen sinks the
bathtubs are frequent
the pools the jacuzzis absolutely
the fountains any body of water no one
should diminish the threat or risk of
any of
we look at them depth of the child we
think neglect to rethink
the amount of carelessness that may have
happened but are these
parents that might mean well and just
kind of are looking the other way
or kind of give me an idea of who might
fall victim to the
absolutely which is as i stated they
don't all become criminal investigations
we show up respond and investigate all
child
deaths uh many of them are not criminal
but there is not a neighborhood i have
not been in
it affects all races all walks of life
it doesn't matter i have been in every
neighborhood throughout this valley
on unfortunate tragedies relating to
child death specifically drowning
and just speak to that consequence for
in case it does
have to go criminals
no absolutely there's beyond even just
the criminal aspect of anything and it's
got to be pretty agree just to rise to a
criminal level
but those scars that the family family's
going to be dealing with
there's no criminal penalty that will
supersede what they already have to deal
with
so that's why we're here to prevent them
to help them heal because
many of us are parents ourselves we
don't want to go through this tragedy we
want to do everything we can to help
everybody else prevent it
thank you very much